- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is focus on the budget
process in the US Congress.
And just as a reminder, that's
one of the major functions
of the United States
Congress is to pass a budget
for the Executive Branch
to decide how much money
the Executive Branch has to
use to actually function.
And when it comes to the budget,
the two most powerful committees are
the Appropriations Committees
in the House of Representatives
and in the Senate.
They get to decide how much money goes
to various departments and programs
in the federal government.
Just for context, let's
get a broad view of what
the federal budget looks like
and how it has changed over time.
So over here you see the
trend from the early 80s
all the way until projected
a few years into the future
at the time of this video being created.
And you can see the absolute
level of the federal budget
has gone from a little under $1 trillion
and it is now approaching $4 trillion.
And this view of the breakdown
of the various spending areas
gives us a better sense of some trends.
As we mentioned in other videos,
there's a significant chunk
of mandatory spending.
Mandatory spending are things that by law
we have already obligated ourselves to.
And the big ones here are
Social Security and Medicare
and you can see that they
have gone collectively
from a little over 20%
of the federal budget
to now approaching almost
2/3 of the federal budget.
Now another chunk of this
budget that we are obligated
to pay is the net interest
on our national debt.
We are borrowers as a country
and so we need to pay interest.
Now everything else here you can consider
to be discretionary.
That would be this national defense piece
right here in purple and then everything
above this net interest piece.
And that's what the Appropriations
Committees are going
to decide on, where to spend that money.
How much does national
defense get and how much
do these other priorities
for the country get?
Now generally speaking, the
amount of money allocated
to various programs and
various departments,
how it is spent tends to be
decided by the Executive Branch.
Congress's job is to set the budget
but that is not always the case.
Congress can also set aside
portions of this budget
for specific projects.
And the setting aside
of parts of the budget
for specific projects
is known as earmarks.
And to make things tangible,
here are some examples
of earmarks from the Highway
Bill that was passed in 2005.
And as you can see, it just lists a bunch
of special projects and
this goes on for tens
and sometimes hundreds of pages.
So here in California,
there's a project to construct
safe access to streets for
bicyclists and pedestrians
including crosswalks, sidewalks,
and traffic calming measures
in Covena, California, $400,000.
If we go down here to number
five, renovate and expand
National Packard Museum
and adjacent historic
Packard facilities, and
that is almost $3 million.
And so one thing that's
probably crossing your mind
is hey, this is a national
highway bill and you have
these little projects that
seem very, very, very local.
And these earmarks here, these set asides,
because they feel sometimes
wasteful or they're being used
more as a political tool versus something
that the federal government
should actually worry about,
sometimes these types of
earmarks are referred to
as pork barrel projects,
pork barrel projects.
And the reason why I introduced
both words are earmarks
are just a general thing.
You can decide whether
they're good or bad.
Many of those earmarks that I
listed, even though they are
for specific projects
in specific locations,
they seemed at least
related to the Highway Bill,
but it would be very reasonable
for some folks to say
why is Congress in the business
of funding these specific projects?
Isn't it their job to just set the budget
to figure out how much the
Department of Transportation
gets and then let them, as
part of the Executive Branch,
decide how to execute on improving
the national highway system
or our transportation system?
And so they would argue that that is pork,
that those are pork barrel projects,
that those are government waste.
Now to get a sense of
how significant earmarks
and debatably pork barrel
have been in the past,
we have this chart from Citizens
Against Government Waste
and it shows earmark
spending from 1991 to 2016.
And you will immediately
notice some things.
Going from 1991 all the
way until about 2006,
you have this steady upward
trend in earmark spending
all the way to the peak in 2006
of $29 billion of earmarks.
But then something interesting happens.
In 2011, it looks like it
gets pretty close to zero
and then it starts trending up from there,
but it's much lower that it was before
and that's because as we get
into this period after 2006,
earmark spending became a
very big political issue.
Some of these projects,
there was famously an earmark
for a bridge to an island
in Alaska that was going
to cost several hundreds
of millions of dollars.
It was later canceled
but it got a lot of press
and a lot of politicians
started to make it their mission
to do away with earmark spending.
Some of these pork
barrel projects were easy
to get people worked up about,
and say, hey look, this is
a sign of government waste.
And so in the end of 2010, both the Senate
and the House of Representatives
passed resolutions
to end earmark spending,
although you can see
that it still exists in
some way, at least according
to the Citizens Against Government Waste.
Now at first, this seems
very good because $29 billion
on things like museums or maybe
bridges that go to islands
that very few people live on does not seem
like a good idea.
It seems like classic
examples of government waste.
But it's also important
to keep it in context.
Remember the federal budget
is approach $4 trillion.
So even in 2006, when the
federal budget was a little
under $3 trillion, this was only about 1%
of the federal budget.
And so even though earmarks,
which often get called
pork barrel projects,
became a lightning rod
for a lot of media attention
because they seemed so wasteful,
in most years, they
represent well under 1%
of the federal budget.
And there are folks who would
even argue that earmarks
are a good thing by essentially
allowing Congresspeople
to set aside an earmark for
something in their district.
It makes it easier for bills to get passed
and it's only costing us
less than 1% to do it,
and it's only something
that's streamlining
the political process.
Other arguments they make is
these earmarks aren't spending
above and beyond the regular budget.
If they do not set aside
this money for these projects
in these various districts
or in these various states,
well, then the Executive
Branch is just going to decide
on how to use that money.
And ideally the Executive
Branch would open these things
up for bid, these would
be competitive processes,
but there's examples
of the Executive Branch
also favoring certain
regions or certain projects.
So the budget could arguably be the same
whether or not there are those earmarks.
It's really a question
of whether it is Congress
that is deciding where
these special projects go
or whether it is the Executive Branch.
Now another term that you might often hear
with the legislative process, something
that helps streamline it,
is the germ logrolling.
Now logrolling can apply
to a lot of things,
not just in terms of
where you spend money.
Logrolling is just the idea
that let's say that I am
Congressperson A and you
are Congressperson B,
and I really like this
bill right over here.
I like bill number one and
you like bill number two,
and I agree to support you,
if you agree to support me.
Here I describe logrolling
where we support
each others bills but we
could even have logrolling
where we support each
others parts of bills.
For example, I'll support
your transportation museum
in your state, if you support
my bicycle path in my state.
So I'll leave you there.
The big takeaways here
are to appreciate the size
of the federal budget,
where it gets spent,
and some of the processes
used to help pass
that federal budget.
We also talked about earmarks
which sometimes get called
pork barrel projects.
And it's interesting
for you to think about
after this video, are
they good or are they bad?
At first, especially when you
look at the media attention,
they seem clearly bad, they seem wasteful.
But when you think about
that they're less than 1%
of the budget, and they might
help streamline the passing
of other important legislation,
maybe making it even
more bipartisan, who
knows, some would argue
that they might not be as
bad as people first believed.
You decide.